vous en voyez peut-être de plus en plus
de 7
ces cigarettes électroniques qui
dégagent une espèce de fumer une buée
apparemment inodore si on ne met pas de
saveur dans cette cigarette électronique
bref ailleurs début de débat qui
s'installe en action très pour ça leur
permet d'arrêter de fumer donc est une
bonne chose
en principe mais d'autres qui sont
contre qui prétendent que ça crée
d'autres mauvaises habitudes
bref dossier avec un usd pâtit depuis
j'ai commencé à cette cigarette là je
n'ai plus cette petite ou là depuis
trois mois
carole gré ne fume presque plus elle va
pas pour moi c'est comme si je prenais
mon pas vous devrez scarlett parce que
j'ai le geste aussi genre voilà bokam
donc puis cette nicotine là qui a le
goût comme d'une cigarette après chaque
touche
elle rejette de la vapeur de propylène
glycol une glycérine végétale à laquelle
on ajoute de la nicotine comme plusieurs
elle a découvert la cigarette
électronique à l'institut de cardiologie
de montréal depuis neuf mois
médecins et infirmières proposent à
leurs patients qui ont tout essayé pour
cesser de fumer de remplacer la
cigarette conventionnelle par la
cigarette électronique
ce à peu près 80% avait passé un quart
est ce que j'ai jamais vue avec les
traitements conventionnels depuis 2009
santé canada n'a autorisé la vente d'
aucune cigarette électronique avec
nicotine mais à voir se multiplier les
nouveaux points de vente
on peut dire qu'il y a une certaine
tolérance un certain flou de plus en
plus de fumeurs va potes ils viennent
choisir le mélange et la saveur qui leur
conviennent ça goûte pauvres et amal
pina colada homme sans saveur qui vont
se rapproche c'est quand même
et depuis que je suis passé à ça mon
envie de nicotine géant nettement de j +
goûts même l'odeur la scarlett me lève
le coeur
le prix moyen des modèles les plus
populaires tourne autour de 80 dollars
il faut ensuite ajouter le liquide à
mettre dans le réservoir et qui contient
différentes concentrations de nicotine
selon les besoins mais c'est plus ou
moins des jeunes gens dans la
quarantaine qui vont venir une personne
seule l'essayer discrètement selon us
leur commerce échappe à la
réglementation santé canada qui sont
fait un grand plaisir de nous envoyer
des lettres
sauf que comme ils ne peuvent pas régir
sûr parce que ce n'est pas un médicament
ont déjà retourné les articles de loi
par écrit ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas
pu parler de leur côté les autorités de
santé publique craignent que la
cigarette électronique nuisent aux
efforts faits jusqu'à maintenant pour
réduire le tabagisme le pot de normes de
fabrication
on connaît pas les effets sur la santé à
long terme on sait pas c'est efficace
pour cette fumée et on s'inquiète que ça
incite les jeunes à se tourner
éventuellement dans le tabac c'est ce
qu'on a prévu en europe au contraire une
baisse du tabagisme puis une
augmentation de cire et épingle aussi la
syrie techniquement le marché du tabac
un sondage vient d'être menée en europe
auprès de 19000 vapoteurs et montrent
qu'ils étaient presque tous des anciens
fumeurs
avant d'adopter la cigarette
électronique d'ailleurs les grandes
compagnies de tabac voit ce marché leur
échapper elles ont commencé à acheter
des fabricants de cigarettes
électroniques
même l'association pour les droits des
non-fumeurs constate que la cigarette
électronique est un moindre mal pour les
fumeurs invétérés voudrait qu'ils
prennent le timbre ou la gomme carette
qui sont les produits les plus
sécuritaires mais est ce qu'on pourra
pas leur offrir un autre choix
mélo des gens sont le son départ d'un
pion dadis culte et arrêter de fumer
donnons leur un autre option mais une
autre option qu'ils soient sécuritaires
et encadrer de façon raisonnable une
douzaine de médecins et scientifiques
ont d'ailleurs demandé à la ministre de
la santé où on a en bronze d'agir pour
permettre rapidement la vente de
cigarettes électroniques sans attendre
d'autres études moi je trouve c'est un
excès de prudence qui est pleinement
justifiée de dire on va reprendre des
études 5 millions de morts par année est
ce qu'on va combien de millions de morts
reste à voir maintenant si les vapes
auteurs auront les mêmes restrictions
que les fumeurs dans les endroits
publics
les médecins qui voient d'un bon oeil la
cigarette électronique pour l'arrêt du
tabagisme ne souhaite pas pour autant
que la vapeur soit permise là où le
tabac est interdite ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada mourir